the european union's competitiveness
council has adopted a new generation of
public and private partnerships
aimed at creating more jobs and boosting
economic growth
the partnerships will contribute to the
launch of large-scale and long-term
innovation projects
under the eu's massive new research
program horizon 2020
which was also formally adopted by the
ministers for the research community
horizon 2020 means valuable funding at a
time that many countries are struggling
to maintain science budgets
the new partnerships will focus on
innovative medicine
more effective diagnostics and
treatments with the aim of improving the
health and well-being of europeans
other partnerships include bio-based
industries aeronautics
electronics fuel cells and hydrogen
in public debate the council agreed a
general political approach
on the european program for monitoring
the earth from satellites
known as copernicus the program will be
used to support the agriculture and
fishery sectors
and will help in disaster response work
including fighting forest fires
elsewhere on the agenda ministers also
reached agreement on a common position
concerning new rules on breaches of
anti-trust laws
a challenge in the car industry among
other sectors
the proposals could make it easier for
victims of cartels
to receive compensation for loss of
business and lost profits